she looks sleepy cuz she is sleepy and
it's only day 2 of Greece member hi guys
my name is grace helping do not know 99
life is different now welcome to grace
member I'm making a video Monday through
Friday through the month of November
will that catch on as a catchphrase
hopefully not that's a lot to say it's
very DIY here on it's grace so we're
gonna get into some fall home decor
because nothing says I have nothing else
to do like changing out the decor in
your home on a seasonal basis yeah I'm
Decorah can be a really fun way to
distract yourself from how sad you
actually feel you can also be
inexpensive it's a fun way to change up
your environment without doing a full
overhaul or a full over fall I'm sad
inside so here's a really quick and
cheap and easy home decor DIY is that
you can do to make your home feel more
in line with the season both weather and
politically speaking
[Music]
for reasons I'm pono's Tamimi decided to
start this video with no audio so you
get a voiceover and then I'll start
talking eventually and it'll be weird
but our first DIY is a birdhouse how far
how a Tom know how festive
I bought this pre-made birdhouse and
Joanne's fabrics like ten dollars but
you can also make your own birdhouse if
you're a [ __ ] monster and then I'm
gonna use these metallic acrylic paints
but you're also super última all that I
also go to Joanne's fabrics and then I
got these brushes also from jo-ann's
fabric so I'm gonna take my metallic
paints and pick a color that I think
truly reflects the current state of our
world gray and then this is where I
decided to turn off the TV and talk into
camera because I knew that my later
voiceover would be hey you're gonna
panic kind of things seem to be done in
our country these days and also the
silver is really reflective so we can
see ourselves in it people that are in
the most amount of power seem to only
want to look at himself just continue to
paint it with the thought I might get it
done first like do it well and here just
a lot of noise in the background too
that's par for the course
oh reference it early par for the course
we've painted it a color that fully
represents our future bleak this is a
birdhouse obviously a shelter meant for
birds and offers safety comfort and the
hope for a successful future
in keeping with current trends we're
gonna put that I making some fun
popsicle sticks is comfrey tape so I
don't have to do any work thank god
that's like the president and just peel
off the tape just start sticking them
right to the front and there you go we
have now officially nonsensically and
very poorly constructed a wall in front
of a structure that was once a beacon of
hope for birds doesn't it make sense
moving on it's one of the most
cost-effective and fun ways to change up
your seasonal decor is with throw
pillows I found this pillow adjoins
fabrics for maybe like $15 and it's
already pretty fall oriented but I
wanted to make it super specific so one
of my tricks is when you see a pillow
that you might like the coloring of I
love this plaid I'm not super into this
you
turn it over and make it into anything
you want wanted a mytrends in pillows is
to put some sort of quote or
inspirational message on there so I
thought I would take this very fall
themed plaid pillow and put a quote on
it from a person that has a lot of
influence all you need for this is some
sort of fabric marker or paint pad and a
quote that you want let's go for it and
I'm done this is a very autumnal also
non-seasonal quote from the leader of
the free world check it out ok I last
fall home decor DIY uses a wooden crate
these are amazing you use them for so
many different things I get this adjoins
fabrics for 10 dollars I'm gonna turn it
into a very resourceful
I'll Tom no home decor items so you can
stain this if you want to go above and
beyond I don't have time for that our
world might completely fall apart at any
moment so I'm going to save some time
but one of the fun things you can do
like the pillow is personalize it so I
have some paint bends here and I'm just
gonna kind of write a personal message
on the front of this then I'm going to
decorate the other end of it now I'm
gonna add the last little bit of accents
tada and there you have it a very fall
themed garbage can
[Music]
well there you go there were my quick
easy cheap ball home decor DIYs
I hope this inspired you tag me on
Instagram or Twitter if you make any of
these at home I'd love to see what you
guys make it home and do not forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
making videos Monday through Friday to
the month of November and you're not
gonna want to miss it unless it is
something that you're gonna want to miss
in which I respect your opinion thanks
for at least giving it some time other
than that I don't know Game six